henri michel vous venez de donner la
composition de l'équipe de france avec
une seule surprise d'une attaque inédite
avec rocheteau et tour eh oui je pense
qu'on peut on peut parler une équipe
classique ottomane derrière et au milieu
devant c'est une nouvelle formule ne
formule que j'avais envie de tenter
depuis quelque temps puisque l'autre
formule on la connaissait avec delaunay
stopyra je crois que c'était l'occasion
de le faire d'autant plus que les deux
garçons sont appelés que ce soir au
château josé touré son temps sont en
bonne forme et je compte sur leur leur
complémentarité sur l'expérience de l'un
et sa mobilité et sur le potentiel
physique de l'autre pour pour nous
apporter
peut-être un peu d'efficacité dans cette
équipe alors lui rugby pro ce match très
au sérieux est ce que l'équipe de france
le prends aussi très au sérieux mais on
a déjà serait l'habitude de prendre tous
les matchs sérieux la dotant tous que
c'est un match avec le label officiel
c'est à dire sa première fois que cette
compétition créée c'est une la coupe
intercontinentale qui opposera le
champion d'amérique du sud au champion
d'europe tous les quatre ans à l'heure
actuelle on ne connaît pas bien de sa
première faute tenant dans quelques
années ce soit nos rencontres
importantes dans dans le calendrier et
puis à travers ce match là aussi pour
nous c'est la meilleure des préparations
qu'on peut avoir en prévision n'est des
trois matchs éliminatoires avec ils
seront décisifs qui nous attend nous
marier trois mois à venir
justement qu'attendez vous de cette
rencontre en prévision des matchs
importants et surtout du match contre la
rda le 11 septembre bien on attend un
vrai match on a toujours beaucoup
d'espoir on attend surtout parce que
c'est le premier match de la saison que
l'équipe de france on retrouve la
plénitude de son jeu qui a paru manquer
quelque peu en fin de saison dernière
je crois qu'on a on en a les moyens et à
travers ce match là je pense à son tour
la plus haute de notre jeu et qu'on en
tire une victoire ce soir la meilleure
de préparation qu'on puisse avoir à voir
nos machines à tour de la coupe du monde
et surtout ce que je voudrais pas c'est
que le doute s'installe à l'intérieur de
deux secondes